[Music]
all right let's go to um oh let's just
stay here let's go to aj in uh nashville
what's up aj
hey uh thanks for taking my call you got
it brother what's up
um i wrote my question down so i didn't
uh you know flower on too much so i
should do something robotic that's why i
should do that i should start writing my
yes okay good job
yes all right what's up
all right um so i have a question about
getting married and before i get married
how
uh i can best prepare myself for the
relationship with my girlfriend's
younger sister
so it's a really long story
i was gonna say this this sounds jerry
springery no
no not not quite that bad okay good good
good good all right so
take me to it
so
long story short she has custody of her
teenage sister
okay um
and i'm 25
and
uh
her younger sister is about to turn 16
so there's not a huge gap between us
okay um so i'm i'm just kind of how old
is your fiance
she is about to turn dirty okay
um
and so our
her parents just out of the picture
um yeah yeah pretty much her dad's
around but he is not uh
eligible for custody i guess there's a
way to put that wow
he's got he's a mess huh
yeah it's a it's a whole mess okay
um so tell me what your concerns are
um
i guess
just uh
setting proper boundaries between like
friendship and also being able to
support
my girlfriend and like decision making
with
uh how to help in her
sister's life sure if that makes sense
yeah absolutely uh when are you actually
getting married
so
that's a thing i actually haven't
proposed to her yet so
i got myself on a little timer here
before this episode comes out
listen here's what would be great the
moment this episode drops have her be
here at the studio and you can propose
here and then we'll just do the wedding
here too
okay all in one day and then you can be
like by the way on the way home we need
to listen to this episode they just
dropped today that'd be fantastic
um so
i'll have to i'll have to look into my
plans and see if that's uh better than
what i already have going on will she
that might be better being this man yes
i don't know
that's like my prom date when i asked
her to prompt she's like i don't know
let me see if there's some other other
people that might be better than you oh
i don't know i don't know if you can
tell from the how early i'm asking this
question i'm a little bit of a planner
in that way yeah you're a little bit
over dramatic so here's here's what i
would tell you
um
don't overthink this
and don't underthink this no let me say
it this way don't overthink this and
don't underplan this okay
here's what i mean by that and i i
hopefully just made your your planner a
little plain our heart so happy he's so
happy
um
you and your new and when you when you
get engaged
you all sit down and establish the
boundaries of your new home together
okay
here's who we are gonna be as a couple
sister goes to the side for just a
moment here is who we are going to be
we're going to be people of hospitality
we're going to be people of character
we're going to borrow money we're not
going to borrow money we are going to
both work or all those questions right
set up your home in fact i recommend uh
premarital counseling i think it's wise
wise-wise just to get with somebody
who's gonna help you answer questions
that you don't even know to be asking
yet okay
so
we're gonna set up the boundaries of our
home
and then we're gonna look at the
inhabitants of our home and this is a
common mistake parents with just uh
biological kids make
they factor who we're gonna be based on
the kids and then the kids end up being
the center of the home okay
so the second one is
you are not this young woman's dad
right right right and you can never
become a pseudo dad
and
you might be the first stable
mature male adult this young woman has
ever ever met
and so you'll have a modeling
responsibility you'll have
accountability responsibility
right but you're not dead see the
difference there
right yes and i think with a 16 year old
i would put that out right in the open i
will not your dad i will never be your
dad
but
i'm 10 years ahead of you in this crazy
life adventure and i got some wisdom and
i will take care of you and i will honor
you and i will be there as
whenever you need
however you need and
here is the rules of this home here's
who we are
okay and it's much easier to have a
conversation beginning with here's who
we are not here's what we're not gonna
do
okay so here's a good example of that
with a 16 year old
you can sit down and say hey we're
getting married
you haven't before but you got a
midnight curfew now
you can start there and you might as
well just declare war right
or
you can say hey in this home
a cornerstone of this family this new
family is we're going to honor our
bodies we're going to be good stewards
of our bodies
and that means we're going to
eat at home more than we eat out we are
going to go for walks as a gang we'd
love to invite you
um and we get sleep we value sleep here
that's just who we are and you got two
years before you can leave if you want
to
um but while you're here this is how we
do this and we're gonna model this okay
you see the difference there
one is one is an invitation and one is a
demand and ultimately as a parent you
always will get to demands at some point
but it's so much better to start with an
invitation
okay
um and then i think you set up
relationship
way upstream
what i mean by that is just talk to your
wife your soon-to-be new wife or your
fiance when she becomes your fiance
and
have things like
uh i challenge you to
a video game once a week or we have
breakfast out on the front porch just
you and her once a week or
i'm going to develop a relationship way
upstream so that when i do have to have
accountability conversations in our home
um there's a context to them
we actually do that now once a month we
have like a
me and her hang out like i take her
to wherever i'm like hey do you want to
do something fun or you know uh
if my girlfriend's off that weekend she
does it with us but if not we keep our
plans going and we'll we'll go to a
waterfall or you know we go to a library
or have plans together and i can like
just kind of model try not i mean model
sounds weird but i just want to be
around her in like a
a positive influence way because i love
that she said she hasn't had that really
you are modeling stability okay but i
also also know how deep this modeling
goes
it's you picking up a piece of trash as
you walk across a parking lot
it's you tipping really really well
even when the service wasn't great
and you tell your um this young woman um
i'm gonna honor this woman with a great
tip
and you show up when you say you're
gonna show up right you see what i'm
saying like she's absorbing everything
because she's got
a part of her brain that is searching
for when you're gonna leave too
because that's all she knows is at some
point the the men in her life pack up
and leave
or they go bananas and the court says
we're stepping in because you're not
safe together
and so you're modeling all the time
which i think is beautiful and great
once you this you all become a family
once you all move in together and this
becomes a
family unit here um
make that once a week
and it can be as simple as um i i
this is how
lame i am i take my own questions for
humans cards
i did it this morning once a week my son
and i go to uh waffle house
and we have breakfast together and we
ask questions this morning we had a long
discussion about what do we want etched
on our tombstone that's one of the
questions
in a million years i would not have
gotten there with my with my 12 year old
son okay but it's once a week it's a
context we talk about our gratitudes we
have little journals that i take with us
and so it's become more of a formal
thing
and it is a little irony
so early i know and then when we get
there it's incredible and i learned more
about him
doing those things so hang on the line
i'm gonna send you all the questions for
humans i got okay the whole the whole
gamut
and you can pick and choose which ones
of those you think would be great
there's parents and teens there are
friends there's any number of them would
work for this context okay
um thank you that's awesome but i think
having some sort of tool this is just a
thing we do together we have breakfast
once a week and i think that would be
really great
yeah that would be awesome because
as much as i try to like connect and be
around her she's into much different
things than i am of course enough yes
well and that's a good thing right and
you're not coming in to shape-shift any
of that stuff but you are coming in to
say here's what stability looks like
and there's not a thing you can do
that's going to push um me and or your
sister away
all right and it may be a conversation
no not maybe it needs to be a
conversation that you have with your
soon-to-be fiance about college planning
about
job training about grades those all
those expectations as a 25 year old
you're getting launched into it not in a
parent role but in a
supportive adult role and it's just
gonna be awkward and weird and
challenging for the next few years i do
think any sort of discipline
um is best done in partnership but with
your
gonna be wife taking the lead on that
because she's got the long-term
relationship she's got custody all that
kind of stuff
maybe down the road you
just you and your wife have a
conversation about you adopting this
young woman all those things are
possible but i think heading into it is
i'm not your dad
and i'm not going anywhere right and i
applaud you brother i applaud you for
already
um inviting this young woman into your
life in a in an organic way in a
compassionate way in a i'm gonna be
stable and i'm gonna show you what that
looks like that's awesome aj
thank you for loving her and dude come
down here do your proposal just be fun
it'll be awesome